okay let's go to the phone lines at six
one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty and see what is on people's minds
starting with our caller from the six
seven eight caller from the six seven
eight area code what's your name where
are you calling from yes I can okay
sorry I I I'm having a hard time hearing
you said are there protests where I'm
living
yeah yeah there's there's been protests
protests in Boston both in the downtown
areas in the Forest Hills area which is
a little bit outside of the city in
Brockton which is really not Boston it's
the Boston area there's been a bunch of
protests yeah my main question is I see
mostly the young people standing up for
you know people like George Boyd and yet
the boomers tend to look they always
send aside to please no matter what they
do why is it that boomers they always
look down upon us forever questioning
the status quo when they were the ones
during Vietnam protesting this desk well
what changed with them that made them so
status quo ish that's interesting well
so there's two parts I mean part one is
once you live with a system for a while
and you feel that the system sort of
works for you you're less likely to
demand that the system be radically
changed you you with me sort of on that
part at least to start with yeah
now I guess the other thing so in terms
of the protests there is no doubt that
the people protesting are
disproportionately younger folks I don't
know that that's hugely surprising it
seems to me that at every era it is
overwhelmingly people between 20 and 40
20 and 45 that are doing the protesting
and I think it's just by that I think I
don't know that that's unique to this
situation when you look at the ages of
arrest it's been mostly like 18 to 35
year olds I don't know that that means
older folks are
if you look at the polling it seems the
country is pretty United on on the Floyd
Fiasco right I just had you know like I
include what my mother who think if it
doesn't involve them my mother only my
mother my own mother things day if it
doesn't involve her and her her kids and
grandkids she shouldn't get involved I
just don't understand how people can
just be so blind well unfortunately it
is not uncommon that a lot of folks
don't really care much about an issue or
consider it seriously until it affects
them look at all these Republican
Congressmen who are anti-gay their whole
lives then their kid their nephew is gay
and they're like you know what I've seen
the light now we need to do this we need
to do that that's a sad reality about
humanity that you stumbled across I
don't think it's unique to your mom yeah
yeah that's it's just like um
Bill Maher called it the empathy gap but
hey I'm gonna let you go thank you for
answering my question that actually
makes a lot of sense thank you all right
thank you my friend great to hear from
you thank you so much